the world championship just ended were
you surprised by anything that
transpired there yeah it was surprising
that Magnus was not showing his best
play biggest strength of Magnus is how
consistent he is and he got some very
good positions if not outright winning
positions and in a couple of middle
games so I was surprised by the level of
his play but but still at the end of the
day he was a better player in the match
so he did win which I think everyone
expected expected Magnus to be a true
favorite and sings definitely didn't go
too smooth for him you know I mean the
way things transpired of course was
bizarre and performances by both players
before being good match I thought that
Magnus Carlsen will win relatively
comfortably but you know he turned out
was almost other way around is he well
he was even thrilling the match at one
point I would say that he got it but not
in the way expected I expected him to
you know keep a tight scope but not by
saving these games three and four and so
on because it was exciting because the
score was always exciting there were
really moments when I thought it's not
going to win so yeah I didn't expect
that to happen I was expecting both
players to be playing well and words
behind us it was not the case yeah I
think that both of them they played
below the average level actually thought
the racket games were really a pretty
high quality when you think there's so
much at stake so much fatigue so much
tension I thought they were really
impressive but the match itself there
were some games that were very exciting
but a lot of them were a bit bit of a
damp squib unfortunately
there's been some controversy about how
rapid chess decided the World
Championship do you think that rapid is
a good way to decide who's the best
player well I mean I think you have to
have you have to have someone who wins
and unfortunately I think if you keep it
as classical there there is a pretty
high chance they're gonna be a lot more
draws you just because it's going to be
14 games or 16 games doesn't mean that I
is going to be broken and so I don't see
the point you have to have a way to
break a tie that is by nature the second
option ideally you'd prefer to be
decided in the regular games and I don't
have a problem with it at all
I think that's fine maybe for 12 rounds
people come to terminal you have to
break the tie somehow and more classical
games that's just too much maybe for the
next World Championship match maybe they
could change the rule a little bit
because to decide the classical world
champion title based on rapid games
doesn't sound right no I actually don't
think I would change anything like that
and you know it was really exciting the
rapid tiebreaks in and we saw some
really impressive chess I think that
most people probably found the last day
of the World Championship the most
exciting at least I did I mean I watch
it closely and I thought it was a
thrilling tie break it could have been
even it was relatively one-sided so if
it had been closer it could have been
even more exciting I think still like
four games of repute it's a serious
match I mean so I I don't have anything
against it but I think we should really
exclude blitz if possible because blitz
is something you know very very
different well you got to end the thing
that's I mean we gave them a chance 1212
classical games a lot of games I mean
let's not kid ourselves okay 24 is more
12 games it's a lot of games I mean here
we're gonna play nine it's going to be a
lot going to be tired twelve games is a
lot of games you have you have a chance
to prove that you are better if you
cannot prove okay you either play play
forever or okay just speed things up